Turn it up
relax man, I don't bite
The night's
Just getting started
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie. Marvel dropped a brand new blade trailer,
so we'll break it all down.
I know there's a bunch of questions about what's
going on with the new Blade movie with Mahershala Ali.
Is Wesley Snipes
going to come back as the version of Blade
in a cameo scene in Deadpool 3 or Avengers
6 Secret Wars
So we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Of course, I'll do more videos
when we get more footage for the actual movie.
When we start learning more about what's
actually going on with the plot
and how Blade is going to fit into the new MCU.
We have a couple details already,
but we don't know everything yet.
they made this trailer announcement on Blades
50th anniversary, too.
It's the year of his debut.
Not the exact date, Blades
first appearance in the comics was in Marvel's
Tomb of Dracula back in April 1973.
so as a little while before this actually dropped
but because he debuted in the Dracula comic book.
That's why a lot of people thought in the original
version of this new Blade movie Marvel's working on
would feature Black Knight in Blade, maybe Moon Knight
teaming up to fight a version of Dracula in the MCU.
Like everybody remembers all the new knight
Dracula memes that was all part of the early hype
around Marvel
finally doing a sense of midnight style darker team up
when they made the initial announcement
back at Comic-Con 2019.
It has been 84 years.
Like think about how long it's been post all the memes
since they announced
that they were going to be making a Blade movie.
Pretty much everybody was like,
Give me the MCU defenders, but darker characters.
And that is basically the Sons of Midnight.
they literally just did a marvel game
based on that whole concept.
it sounds like the game that they're making verbally.
They plan to come out alongside the new Blade movie.
Does it take advantage of the synergy
They do that all the time with the big video games
and the big Marvel movies.
sometimes like the past few years,
there have been a bunch of big delays.
So the way that messing up the timing of the release of
the games in the movies and it doesn't quite work out
but for example this is part of the reason
why they're making a new Wolverine game,
because Wolverine is coming back in a really big way
the next couple of years to huge Jackman's
character in Deadpool three,
then a couple of years after that in secret wars.
so between Deadpool three and probably 2027
when Secret Wars
is actually going to come out,
they have a few years to finish that Wolverine game.
is basically the same idea with this new Blade game
just starting at the beginning of the trailer.
There's a couple of Easter eggs in here
that you probably spotted.
it starts with him
at what looks like his regular barbershop.
He's been visiting in Paris, France.
It just looks like an ally of his.
Here is cutting his hair in the middle of the day
because he is known as the Daywalker.
Notice the large cross to some of the other
religious markings around the door
to help protect it against vampires
inside the Marvel Universe.
Just generally, vampires are weak against true
religious artifacts like crosses holy water.
They hate garlic.
They operate more like traditional vampires.
You've seen in movies, TV shows, stories, Basically,
what you saw in all the Wesley Snipes Blade movies,
when the camera slowly moves into the barbershop,
you can see de transitioning.
Tonight is the public announcer in the city broadcast
the shelter in place,
warning to all the regular humans, warning them
to lock themselves inside for their own safety.
they're in the middle of a vampire epidemic.
So apparently, like the public in general knows
that there are vampires that exist
in the original Marvel stories
and they kind of get into this during the Wesley
Snipes
Blade movies, regular people don't know that vampires
exist, like regular citizens
go about their days, their normal lives.
without really knowing much about the supernatural.
Just in general.
Not just vampires, but like all things doctor strange
magic monsters like the ones from werewolf by night,
everything connected to that world essentially
they kind of got into this during the recent Werewolf
by Night movie that they aired on Disney,
plus explaining how their secret monster Hunting
society, led by Ulysses Bloodstone in the Bloodstone
family, was largely
a secretive endeavor that the normal world
didn't understand or know about inside the MCU.
If it wasn't clear.
Werewolf by night took place in present day relativity,
like after the events of Avengers Endgame.
So the idea is that most of the world
doesn't really know about what's going on with the
supernatural side, like the supernatural creatures
in general, probably the best example
that and like the recent Marvel characters
that pop up, or Kamala Khan, for instance, Ms.
Marvel, who's a super big Avengers fan
girl, has all their paraphernalia all over her room.
She, like most of the regular world,
knows all about the final battle Avengers Endgame.
They knew who Thanos is.
They knew the Qatari. But. For example, Ms..
Marvel does not know that man thing exists
or that werewolf by night exists.
She also probably doesn't know
that blade exists or vampires,
but because vampires would be like a pop culture thing,
like there would have been movies
about vampires in the MCU,
She would have grown up watching.
She probably understands the concept of vampires,
and because she knows
magic is real, all the supernatural stuff is real.
She knows that Doctor Strange exists.
She probably has some fanfiction that she's written
because that's the whole thing.
She writes fan fiction about The Avengers,
that she probably wrote stories about vampires,
other supernatural creatures,
or at least have some theories that they might exist.
Like, wait a minute, If magic is real,
does that mean that vampires are also real to.
But she's never actually seen a vampire werewolf
by night or any supernatural creatures like that.
Yet during the trailer inside the barber shop
you can see Blade getting his hair cut.
His hair does grow still for those people that wonder
like notice all the crosses, the religious artifacts
all over the room, like wall to wall crosses
and other artifacts meant to protect the barber.
when the barber turns up the music on his iPad.
Notice all the headlines in French.
The first one reads
Takeover of a popular social network by SE.
I don't know who that is.
Probably just some character in the context of the game
or some corporation in the context of the game.
maybe one that's owned by vampires.
Like maybe a vampire owned company.
The next one says explosives remain untraceable.
And the third headline reads
Tense gatherings in major intramural districts
with a picture of the Eiffel Tower.
I think mostly just to remind people
that this is happening in Paris, France.
If the headlines in French didn't clue you into that
all the headlines just meant to set the vibe
for what's going on when the story picks up,
like there's attacks all over the place,
people freaking out all over the districts.
I'm not sure the picture of the woman on the shelf is,
but there's like a bunch of pictures
of different types of haircuts.
That's probably what it is.
Notice the Barber cuts himself
when he's testing his blade
about the cut blades here
and freaks out a little because it is blade.
He is part vampire,
so he grabs his cross just a little bit.
Like he holds it
just a little bit before he gets closer to him.
Blade joking about not biting him
when he gets close with the blade.
That's part truth sometimes.
Very rarely he does bite.
But like 99% of the time he does not by people
and just as he starts,
a red warning light comes on illuminating the shop.
As power cuts out all over the city
and gunshots are fired in the street nearby,
Then we basically get a blade suit up montage
and they actually mirror
a lot of shots from the original Wesley
Snipes Blade movie in this two
part of the idea being the gangs of vampires
have set loose and are going around the city
because the sun has gone down.
It is time for Blade two, so to speak, Go to work.
they ever really said
much about what the actual story is going on here.
Beyond the page like Blade in Paris,
France, hunting vampires.
We don't know who the main villain is going to be
and whether or not they'll be any cameos from other
big Marvel characters or specifically any other Marvel
Supernatural characters like Ghost Writer,
The Sons of Midnight.
Anyone else Recently, Mahershala Ali
also just said their newest version of the Blade
movie was looking good finally,
and they start filming it soon.
That's supposed to be in late 2024.
Next year we'll see about that.
That would mean that
they would release the Blade movie in 2026,
which is probably when this video game
is going to get released.
Do there been like five different scripts and stories
for The Blade movie
since they originally announced it back in 2019.
That's how long ago the Kevin Feige
announced this movie, that's one of the differences
in Mahershala Ali is Blade versus
other Big Marvel characters in the movies.
He specifically came to Kevin Feige
with a meeting discussing
doing general things in the future
and asked to play Blade
instead of Kevin Feige going to him saying,
Will you play our new version of Blade
So the whole idea is that Kevin Feige at the time,
this is like a couple of years ago
when this was happening.
At the time
he had no plans to actually make a Blade movie.
that's why they've been so fine,
just like pushing it off into the distance,
delaying it like, you know, we never really knew
where this is going to fit into the Marvel Universe.
So we'll just keep pushing it
and maybe we'll figure out a good place for it.
but here's the thing.
They originally plan on releasing the movie
a couple years ago.
Like a long time ago.
That's why they debuted the character
for the first time during that Eternals Black Knight
Post-Credits scene
that was Mahershala
Ali his voice as MCU Blade just off screen.
part of the reason why they did that,
like where they put him in that Black Knight scene
specifically, is because Kit Harington's
Black Knight in Ebony
Blade were meant to appear
in the original version of The Blade movie.
Now the movie has changed a couple of times since
they've changed the writers and changed the scripts.
But part of the big idea here
is that the ebony blade would be something
that would have existed since the time of Camelot
for hundreds and hundreds of years
and because Blade has been around since the 1920s.
He's come across the ebony blade
in the previous versions
of The Black Knight
as he's been hunting vampires for a long, long time.
so I think they intended
on setting up the whole backstory that members of Dane
Whitman's family, who had been the Black Knight
before him going back to the time of Camelot.
And the MCU had all fought supernatural creatures
with the ebony blade like Black Knight Vampire Hunter.
But across the ages and because part of the movie
was supposed to take place in the 1920s to tell Blade's
origin story,
he would have come across the Black Knight of that era,
which would have been, I believe,
just based on the timeline, would have been Dane
Whitman's great grandfather
or part of that generation in his family.
they just brought another writer onto the project.
Kevin Feige confirmed that it would be rated R,
so breathe
easy for those of you
that want R-rated R Blade franchise.
They lowered the budget a little bit too.
It'll be like a $100 million movie,
which is still a lot of money.
Now, I know a ton of people are asking about Wesley
Snipes coming back and cameo
as his version of Blade in like Deadpool
three or Avengers Six Secret Wars.
There have been a lot of rumors about that.
I do not expect him to come back in Deadpool three
just because it sounded like his relationship
with Ryan Reynolds was kind of strained
because of what happened on Blade Trinity.
But because that was so many years ago
that could have changed.
Like it could be water under the bridge at this point.
It was a long time ago when that movie happened.
That was before he even started developing a Deadpool
movie.
is always possible that he comes back in Avengers
six Secret Wars and some kind of small cameo scene,
or he has a small cameo
in some way as a different type of character,
or like another vampire
related character in the new Blade movie two.
Whatever we wind up hearing about all those characters,
of course I'll do more videos, we get some more blade
footage, I'll do more blade videos.
If you have any special requests or questions
about what's going on with Blade
just in general or the other Supernatural characters,
just write them in the comments below.
There was a bunch of new Deadpool
3 footage that just dropped.
Click here to watch that and click here
for all my other recent
Deadpool three videos, especially all the teasers
that Ryan Reynolds has been releasing.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!